[Applause]
we are live in Nashville with an amazing
audience let's hear it for them for you
guys
now all right now let's get to this
American voters are screaming from the
rooftops again give us anybody but Joe
Biden more than half a voters want to
see the other candidates throw their
hats in the ring for the 2024
presidential race
and even the big guy himself seems to
want someone else to run I want to talk
about Governor Nome want to thank him
he's been one hell of a governor man
matter of fact he could do anything you
want he could have the job I'm looking
for and while Gavin Newsome measures the
drapes at the White House he could face
some Fierce competition from this
Hollywood meast star Dwayne The Rock
Johnson was on Capitol Hill amid Buzz
about a possible presidential bid the
rock also revealing to Joe Rogan how
Democrats truly feel about Joe
Biden I have friends who support Trump I
have friends who support Biden I have
friends do you really have friends who
support Biden come on well no no no no
no here here's what I do I have I have
friends thank you that's a good check CU
that's important this is important
context they support the Democratic
party I have friends who are loyal to
the party yes and they're they're
Progressive right
all right Tyrus I'll start with you here
you've got this Wonder yeah all right so
the rock he's an athlete he's in great
shape he's self-made he's a businessman
now he wants to throw his hat in the
ring for president what do we know about
him okay well first of all that's not
what he did okay he went to the White
House to work on trying to get
recruitment up in the military so let's
say focused on what he really came to do
okay that drives me literally anybody
who dri R by the White House with their
window down are you running for
president because they just don't want
Biden
anymore he came there to get our
recruitment up because recruitment in
this country with the exception of the
Marines is down astronomically no one
wants to be a police officer anymore
can't blame them nobody wants to join
the military anymore can't blame him so
that's what he's there for because in
his time in the WWE my time in the WWE
they have always supported the troops at
a high level we do free shows for him we
travel we support and the WWE has been a
great vehicle in with work relationships
with the Navy are and that's what he was
there for was to talk about how do we
get recruitment up and everyone came up
with the with the plan get by
out okay so this is an official
announcement you're speaking on behalf
of rock he is not running for president
I don't know what he's doing I have
enough time juggling this Juggernaut
maybe I'll run for
president for
President that might work you never know
all right all right Jesse the next one's
to you I want you to take a listen to
this Gavin Newsome
after today would you still refer to
president she as a dictator this is a
term that you used earlier this year
well look he is I mean he's a dictator
in the sense that he he is a guy who
runs a country that is uh
country all right so that's blinking
when President Biden calls G Jinping who
we just spent a year trying to get a
meeting with calling him a dictator and
even the secretary of state blinkin is
like
n what's your well I think everybody
winces when Joe Biden talks and Chi is
not a dictator he's Joe Biden's personal
banker I think it was
like sorry Jess thanks a
lot but what the Rock said is
interesting because there is no Biden
voter I've never seen a Biden bumper
sticker I've never seen a Biden t-shirt
a Biden hat have you spoken to your
mother yeah my mother isn't a Biden
voter she's an anti-trump voter and
that's what all the Democrats were last
time and now everybody wants him to
leave because he was supposed to get
elected and then pass the torch he's
like the guy at the arcade who's too old
to be there and he's playing the little
basketball hot shot and all the kids are
like hey hey old guy C you you said it
was our turn next and he's just going
away and that's why people are
frustrated and they want Nome and
they're throwing up this trial balloon
because let's be honest K's popped and
you must be upset if your kamla to
listen to Joe Biden endorse Gavin Nome
but everybody loves Gavin he's a tall
white man and the Democrats if he wins
will hold their nose and vote for a tall
white man because to Democrats we stink
all right Dana I'm gonna go to you so I
mean Gavin new some last year is at the
White House with that slick back hair
he's got his jacket thrown over his
shoulder what do you think his plans are
well remember when he went there Joe
Biden was out of the country so that it
was like wait what is he doing there but
I actually think that that Gavin Nome
has been a very good surrogate for Joe
Biden if you're going to have a
surrogate somebody who's going to speak
on your behalf you could do worse than
having Gavin Newsome do it and
inevitably people are going to say well
is aren't you just trying to run and
undermine him but I don't think gavan
has shown that he's trying to undermine
him there are other ways to do that like
Dean Phillips the congressman from
Minnesota he is definitely trying to
undermine Joe Biden Gavin Newsome might
decide to run for president but he
doesn't really seem to have the support
there's not a groundwell of support by
the party faithful right I it's almost
as if Gavin Newsome is trying to make
himself a thing and the Democratic party
is not quite there yet but maybe they
could get there but but do we even know
what the Democrat Party is thinking
because nobody's saying anything they're
just like we're all supporting Joe and
nobody's saying anything that is saying
something and that's the normal thing to
do even 69% of the Democrats don't want
him to run yeah and I was looking back
at articles that Nate silver himself who
was dissing Joe Biden a few days ago
wrote In 2011 about Obama being toast
right when Mitt Romney was up Five
Points around this time and then lo and
behold Obama went on and very successful
second term won that election I I think
he was being polite to Gavin Nome he was
being hosted in his State they obviously
made a huge effort they cleaned up I
know we joked about it but yes they they
cleaned up um and also XI Jin ping
couldn't have been that mad he gave us
the pandas big deal we're getting more
pandas which everyone should be excited
about if you have a meeting with the
dictator of China and you're deliverable
is we got a couple of pandas that there
was more not good
enough all
right I'm very outnumbered today it's
usually four against one but this is
like 200 against one anyway no there's a
Democrat over there get him
out someone was nice to me in the
hallway I I but you know on top of that
Biden his his you can't call it his
administration but someone on his behalf
said it was extremely wrong for Joe
Biden XI jinping's group said it was
wrong for Joe Biden to say what he said
to call him a dictator as soon as he
left town you know I mean you know Joe
isn't doing so well hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news by any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now